>>
So, I work for Brightkite. Brightkite is a
location-based social network. It allows you
to have, you know, friends and things like
other social networks do. But, it’s more
about saying what’s going on at a certain
place, so places are very important to Brightkite.
I can check in at a place like Moscone Center
or even, like, Google I/O and then I can post
the stream of notes and photos and also see
other people that are doing the same thing
around me. Discovering interesting thing happening
around me is kind of what Brightkite is all
about.
>> What was to be your motivation for creating
Brightkite?
>> What?
>> Your motivations for creating?
>> So, I didn’t create Brightkite. I’m
just the mobile developer. I think the motivation
was to get place, to be an important thing-—to
be an important aspect of social networking
and annotating the real world is a real important
feature too. So, like when I post a stream
of photos at some place, somebody could come
back later and see these things that are taking
place there and that’s kind of an interesting
thing to see about what’s going on at places.
>> So, you choose the Android Application,
can you tell us a little bit about that techno-decisions
regarding that?
>> Yeah, I mean, any device that has a GPS
is going to be something that is really important
part of our platform and Android devices are
going to be one the first class citizens for
sure. There is already an iPhone Application
and so the Android Application is doing a
lot of things that the iPhone Application
already does but we need to make sure that
we’re supporting that. It’s also interesting
to us to be able to do some of the things
that you can do on Android, like it’s great
that your application is part of an ecosystem
of applications on the user’s phone. So,
we want to do some things down the line and
take advantage of that.
>> Okay, people really like hearing “war
stories” but—so, is there anything particularly
difficult thing that you were able to encounter
and (inaudible) it out?
>> So, the one thing was working with the
camera, if you just want to call out to the
camera and get a quick snapshot, the version
1 and 1.1 would just give you a small—scaled
down image when it came back from there. We
needed more than that, so we have to kind
of build our own. We got passed that by looking
at the source which is a very cool part of
Android development as well. You can see what
Google did to build the applications that
are already on your phone. So, we have to
check out those-—check out the source and
kind of build things that way. Another thing
that was pretty tough was scanning and installing
the application the way we wanted. That was—-I
would like that to be a little bit better
in the future--that’s one request that I
would have. A little bit easier to make some
of the, like, Tab Navigation is a common feature
of Android applications and it’s pretty
tough. We just basically had to build around
Tab navigator to make it look the way we want
it. Again, looking at the source helped us
a bit there.
>> What’s your favorite aspect of the Android
development channels?
>> I really like the fact that you can easily
deploy it at any phone and tests instead of
going through a provisioning process. That’s
pretty nice, ADB has been pretty helpful,
I like the GPDs that come in a command line
and fire off some quick things like geo-testing—-that’s
pretty nice. I already used it and I’m familiar
with the Eclipse, or already using what’s
familiar with the Eclipse so, I like using
Eclipse.
>> And are there any features that you can
do on the Android platform that you weren’t
able to do one on here?
>> Yeah, so, this is coming in a later version
of the iPhone SCK. We were able to get in
Maps integrated right in easily which is,
you know, a couple lines of code—-that was
a pretty nice feature and also the background
tasks are pretty nice, background services.
So, we got—we’re taking advantage of those
to look up to when there’s new friend request
or new messages and bringing that up in the
Notification Bar. So, that’s a pretty nice,
nice feature we could take advantage of.
>> Okay, and are there any tips or tricks
you could offer, you know, other people would
like to come up in the Android platform?
>> For anybody coming in to the platform,
I would say, read the source. That’s a great
resource that Google made available. Figure
out how they build the Apps that are closest
to the App that you want to build and see
how they’re doing things. The documentation
is getting a lot better but you can always
see what’s happening in the source, that’s
important.
>> Okay, thank you very much and enjoy the
rest of the show.
>> Thanks, it’s been great so far.